and for more on this we are joined this
morning by CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger Jill thank you so much
for being with us good morning you know
I want to start with going back maybe
six days or a week at this point it
seems like this banking crisis really
came as a surprise to so many people how
did the collapse of one institution in
California lead to the potential
collapse of the entire banking system
you know Christina just mentioned a core
Concept in banking and finance and that
is confidence and when we look at one
situation it's kind of easy to explain
it so we say oh Silicon Valley Bank they
did a lot of business with technology
they loaded up on Long dated bonds but
the reality is the way this moves from
one institution to another is that
people get spooked we lose our
confidence and we then say what other
Banks were like Silicon Valley Bank
what's going on there and you kind of
lift up the hood and you check it out to
be clear for anyone watching right now
if you have less than 250 000 in an FDIC
the insured institution you are fine and
even for those with more than two
hundred fifty thousand dollars perhaps
if your institution comes under trouble
there could be a rescue it's not
explicit but I think there's some
implicit out uh guarantees that are
floating around out there so there are
now four Banks we're seeing in crisis
and while they each have their own
problems did any of them have any
singular point in common I think what
this really does make us look at is what
happens when interest rates are really
low for a really long time so if you
look at pre-pandemic interest rates
environment generally pretty low they
went even lower amid the pandemic
remember we were at zero percent
interest and what that does is it
encourages risk-taking think of it this
way when we all got we saw people
getting stimulus checks or you were
piling up savings during the pandemic
people said well why would I want to put
that money in a zero percent checking or
savings account and then many people
said oh well maybe I'll buy crypto or
meme stock and it encourages risk taking
because you're not getting interest
elsewhere that happens at an
Institutional level at Banks I can't get
interest in by keeping my money in cash
I'll buy longer dated treasuries okay
well what happens when interest rates
rise all of a sudden that risk exposure
is on steroids and what we have seen
across all of these institutions is a
commonality this is what happens when
the FED raises rates very quickly
they're sort of slamming the brakes on
and all of a sudden someone's going
through the windshield and the someone
are these banks that took the most risk
well given all of that I mean the FED is
going to be meeting later on next week
and they're going to be making a big
decision what do you think is going to
happen out of that you know when you
talk to economists they're sort of split
half of them are saying they're going to
be a be pausing their interest hikes
because there's so much systematic risk
right now but I speak to I would say
another half that say they're probably
going to raise my by a quarter of a
percentage Point inflation remains high
and from the fed's perspective if they
just sort of say a quarter of a
percentage point it's like hitting the
the golf ball straight down the Fairway
it's not an eccentric thing to consider
that we're raising rates to fight
inflation we don't want to necessarily
signal to the whole world that we're so
freaked out that we're going to pause on
rates but again it's 50 50 and I think
it's going to be interesting to see that
press conference with Jerome Powell
after the decision quickly is this the
end the end of what
you won't see any more uh I can't say
that we're in the eye of the
what I really do really do is that there
is a lot of negotiations going on this
weekend to sell banking assets and Banks
themselves all right Jill Schlessinger
we thank you thank you